ok so scheiße sie es eigentlich auch
nicht aus so die sind halt vorne ganz
okay hey leute was gab herzlich
willkommen beim neuen video
ich bin gerade mit mir was geht ab alles
gut ausgeht wir sind gerade extra haben
eine halbe weltreise gemacht es ist so
heftig war aber ich habe heute einen
termin hier in hamm kennt man das auf
jeden fall habe ich ja gestern
angekündigt meine haare werden bisher in
special neu und wird ihn drauf und hab
das klar geht aber wir machen
ich verrate erstmal noch nicht so viel
wert ist vielleicht sehen auf jeden fall
habe ich war gestern schon gesagt und
zwar der youtuber der damals auf youtube
gemacht hat die er hat immer so eine
mischung ich kann mal kurz im bild ein
wenn ich hoffe das geht klar man müsste
eigentlich so vielleicht auch nur von
den haaren dass er so aus und ich finde
das wirklich so geil irgendwie so oder
fühlst das nicht geil
und wer auch so gedacht das könnte schon
stehen deswegen check mehr als ein warm
up miguel hatte das ja auch mal so in
die richtung nur seine haare sind
deutlich länger als meine
deswegen ich weiß gar nicht ob das schon
funktioniert so dass so eine mischung
zwischen raster und rechts keine ahnung
gehen jetzt erst mal da hin und fragen
mal die schlauen afrikaner sind das
nicht genau wie es gleich rein
denkst du dass du gut aussehen
ich weiß nicht vielleicht machen wir so
vielleicht könnt ihr das wird also dann
sind meine haare einfach so gehen so
hoch und stehen so unheimlich von geben
jetzt von heißen ich habe gestern zu
angerufen da geht so eine frau randi
sagte hallo die freiheit drei mal das
gleiche ich habe es nie verstanden
dann sagt er einfach günstig und legt
auf 50 das heißt nur es kostet 50.000
leute wie sie muss den laden sollte ich
bin mir der karte schaut mal hier
der alex ist schon da drin ich habe uns
kurz was zu trinken wohl trotz product
placement nahm an er war solid so sieht
der laden von draußen aus richtig krass
man wie in america sowie dienste rein
quadrant der muss mit diesen die
hessische es hat diese bänder
gummibänder gummibändern zuvor mit vier
tagen laufen ja was geht leute wie es
wahrscheinlich schon sofort gesehen habt
da ist irgendwas anders als sonst ich
bin jetzt bei mir zu hause und habe
jetzt erst mal eine cap aufgesetzt ich
bin auch mal gespannt wie meine eltern
gleich hergehen werden auf jeden fall
es sieht gerade noch ein bisschen
scheiße aus also schon so ich persönlich
finde es schon scheiße weil da sind
überall gummibänder drinnen das muss
irgendwie noch vier tagen so bleiben
dann müsste es immer weiter drehen keine
ahnung was das jetzt genau ist ich habe
einfach dieser frau das bild gezeigt was
wir jeden schon mal eingeblendet hat von
diesem youtube hat er jetzt kein youtube
markt und die meinte so also ich hab das
nicht genau verstanden aber sie meinte
sogar zwei wochen blabla ich so zwei
wochen hält das es geht jetzt also ich
denke das sieht dann zwei wochen
ungefähr so aus und jetzt wollt jetzt
natürlich alle seeleute okay okay so
schlimm ist es auch nicht aber
verspricht wir bitten nicht zu lacht das
komische war auch ich habe bis jetzt zu
drei vier leute nach ihren meinungen
prägten die meinen alles sieht gut aus
und ich dachte okay so scheiße dies
eigentlich auch nicht aus so weit vorne
ganz ok
ihr müsst euch vorstellen
beziehungsweise sehr wahrscheinlich auch
hier sind überall noch so gummibänder
drin die gene raus und dann verdecken
die wirklich komplett den ganzen kopf
und die müssen ja auch noch ein bisschen
wachsen
aber ich finde gerade es ist okay so
halten es ist halt auf jeden fall was
anderes und ich versuche jetzt wirklich
so dass eine herausforderung für mich
dass das halt so in zwei wochen wirklich
geil aussieht ich denke dass solche
hinkriegen
ja also leute schreibt auf jeden fall
mal eure meinung dazu in die kommentare
oder wenn es wirklich cool findet dass
ich so was mal gemacht habe oder wenn
ihr findet das nikolaus dann lass mir
doch einfach mal daumen nach oben da
würd mich persönlich sehr interessieren
ja danke auch an e mail der ist ja mit
gekommen also checkt auf jeden fall mal
seinen youtube channel sein neuestes
video in der beschreibung und wollte
auch vielleicht nur wenn ihr bock hat
für ihn auch auf seinem link einfach der
kojote oder emir spahic keine ahnung
einfach worten würde mich sehr freuen
habe ich ihm versprochen dass ich das
auf jeden fall noch erwähnen dass was
ansonsten mit diesem video
ja das habe ich gemacht na ja im
endeffekt das sind notare was sagen habe
über eine person aus eigentlich gar
nicht deswegen ja aber ich will auch gar
nicht weiter laben sonntag kommt um 14
uhr das nächste video 300 ps